[Music]
let's talk about wreck-it ralph
congratulations number one movie this
weekend is that good number one
i like the way you did that and then is
this right the director
uh one of the reasons that he asked you
to come in for this role was because
he's such a big fan of your book the
bedwetter yeah i didn't realize that
until we started doing press and the
director rich moore who's so great i
guess he he mentioned that he had read
my book and he kind of started basing
this character vanellope
on young me and it i didn't realize that
but it i was so connected to her it made
sense you know because it's she's this
glitch she's she's in a racing game
called sugar rush and they won't let her
race because she's a glitch
and all the characters are from video
games yeah it's it's video it's an
arcade after dark and all the video
games come to life
and um and i understand that you know
like the lesson is kind of that glitch
you have that that thing that makes you
that you think you'll be ashamed of for
your whole life you know your your
downfall if you let it can be your
superpower you know it can can end up
being an asset and i felt that way you
know i was a bedwetter
you know my book was called the
bedwetter and i was a bedwetter well
into my teens and i had to go to sleep
away camp and i had so much humiliation
that for me doing stand-up was just not
at all daunting because the idea of
bombing in front of strangers was
nothing compared to wetting your bed
every night at sleep away camp i could
yeah
you know when you're a bed wetter conan
i realize there's only one group of
people you can feel better than
um
squeeze that i squeeze that in
it just occurred to me that you're here
to promote a disney movie
[Applause]
everything with the ah the iphone and
the i love it at disney i know but at
disney right now they're watching and
their heads are blowing up i know soon
stop her
wait a minute let's watch a little more
uh
this is a doll this is a sign that
you've really made it there's a
vanellope
doll yes that uh is this is fantastic
she talks yeah you press her throat
which is weird right he's got a date
with destiny
wow cute
i'm not a glitch taffeta i've got
pixlexia
let's call clowns what they really are
smiling murderers wait a minute
i don't think that's true i have oral
herpes
well a fine disney product
available in stores just in time for
christmas not only are you banned from
disney world now but we are too
yeah
wreck it ralph we have a clip uh
anything you need to tell us about this
clip this is an actual real clip
and
that never happens on this show it's
when ralph of wreck-it ralph fame john c
reilly who's brings so much
warmth okay i'm sorry uh when he meets
my character vanellope for the first
time let's take a look
hey
are you a hobo
no
i'm not a hobo but i am busy okay so you
go go home what's that didn't hear you
your breath is so bad it made my ears
numb listen i try to be nice
you're mimicking
me
okay
that is rude and this conversation is
over
i wouldn't grab that branch if i were
you i'm from the candy tree department i
know
double stripes break a toy
[Applause]